hey guys this is andrew for
tradingcensus.com so let me quickly
introduce myself i've been working as a
professional trader for the past six
years in hong kong
and right now guys i'm doing youtube
videos because i want to pass the
knowledge guys
and most importantly i want to explain
to you how i use
the different tools and techniques to
make money on
the markets so if you want to know about
all the stuff
especially if you want to learn how to
do it yourself you guys are in the right
place
so today i want to make an update on amc
let's get into it
[Music]
bloody week i know for for all the amc
gme apes that hold the position
but let's analyze what is happening so
first on the short term so i'm gonna
on the hourly time frame guys everything
here consists
of finding support and resistance levels
the support levels are telling you
where you can increase your positions
and the resistance level are telling you
when they are overcome if the price
action is going to go higher or not
very quickly in green this horizontal
trend line is actually my strongest
support level
why because i had a reaction here and i
had a reaction here and even
a bit here but once again the most
recent past is the most important so
here i have some reactions
and here you can see rejected rejected
again
we go higher retested we go higher all
right one
two three four reaction in the recent
past so this is what we call a
consolidation
and here guys i don't like what happened
because the last hour
trading hour so this video is done on
the 24th of march
has actually broken this on the hourly
timeframe but
right away in aftermarket we went higher
so this is very interesting this is not
broken guys
to be broken you need to have two
consecutive candles all right it is
broken on the hourly time frame but it's
definitely not broken on the four hours
time frame
we are lower then we go higher so
on the forward time frame which is most
important time frame to
to trade on uh we didn't break
this level on the hourly time frame it
might be a fake breakout so it's going
to be very interesting to notice what is
going to happen here then the
different scenarios if we actually break
it guys
all right don't panic it's all right
okay it's all right the next support
level is at 7.50
once again i was telling you guys that i
was actually bullish
of course on the long term but that 1050
11 call it whatever you want is actually
a very
strong support level to watch because it
was the trendline that i had here
and once it's broken guys it might be
the beginning of
a momentum shift and here we broke it we
tested it we went lower so the momentum
has shifted
and we are perish on the short term so
what can we expect different things
either we
hold above the strength line and we can
develop higher
or we actually break it and something
that is usually happening i'm not going
to do idiot wave counting here
but he's an abc all right so an abc
going to 750
is something that is on the table but
once again guys if this happens don't
panic you know
it's it's all right this is just the
usual price action development
if i check on the longer term guys so if
i go on a daily time frame
look guys how the price action is
actually developing it's very bullish
all right so even if we go to 750
it's still gonna be very bullish why
because uh we have
this on the longer term we have this
trend line here
so we have actually two different trend
lines we have this
steeper trend line that has been broken
retested but look guys what happened
here
it was re-tested but it was very messy
all right so the level was
6 20. we went a bit lower fake breakout
and then we went higher all right
so this is what is actually happening
again
on this trend line here that is a bit
more flat i don't like to see that we
are coming back
below this level because it was broken
usually it's retested and then we go
higher
and here so once again the aftermarket
is at 9.50 so in
aftermarkets it's not broken but if it's
broken here
it's all right guys you know we can go
to 750 so 750
is here guys and even if we have this
abc
that i just said the price action is
still bullish we can
see a bit of this fake breakout before
going higher
so once again guys uh the reason i'm
bullish
on all this stuff is i can see
a lot of options trending on the very
high strikes
this is creating some upside gamma this
is going to be you know something very
tough to handle for all the market
makers hedge funds that are left short
gamma
because of this short options they have
against retail investors
and this is creating some you know short
squeeze gamma squeeze call it whatever
you want
and we have this mechanisms that are
taking place
for the past year and they're gonna keep
taking place so that's it for me guys
watch out what is gonna happen around
the 950 level
if we actually hold above or not if we
don't probably we're going to go to 750
before bouncing back
so if you enjoyed this video please
don't forget to click on the sub like
and bell button and you're gonna be the
first to know when i upload anything new
and stay close to show i'll see you guys